and thank you very much for being on the
program this morning we just heard from
kirstan we're in the interview he I
asked him if he really believes that
Rishi Cena doesn't think pedophiles
should go to prison as in the attack ad
that labor put out and he says yes
what's your reaction to that well I
think first of all I think people listen
to that will think that's nonsense the
you judge people I think in politics by
what they do people remember it wasn't
that long ago that the prime ministers
said of a task force specifically to
deal with one aspect of that issue which
is to deal with grooming gangs which is
a subject the labor doesn't even want to
talk about so I think if people judge
the Prime Minister as actions they'll
see that the substance of that ad was
nonsense I think the second aspect is I
think politics also ought to be focused
on you know what people actually do and
the policies they set out and I think
personal attacks are not very helpful
many many politicians you know
particularly female politicians have to
put up with a lot of abuse online abuse
and I think all people in leadership
positions should be trying to conduct
politics I think with a slightly
different tone so I think it's a very
disappointing approach from him but I
don't actually think the public will
will buy it actually and I guess
Kirsten's argument is that look it's
right to focus on the number of people
who have been let off for some of these
really serious clients and the
conservative's record on crime over the
last 13 years well look it's fair to
focus on policy but that isn't what
they're doing in the attack ads and
actually we've got very tough laws on
those serious offenses but in the end
sentences are set by judges
um you know no no one's I don't think
anyone's turning around pretending that
KIA storm was responsible for all of
those sentences that took place when he
was a member of the sentencing Council
and actually responsible for setting
those rules I mean he does take
responsibility for that at least well
yeah he might say that but the fact is
if he's going to apply his own argument
then he has to say that he's guilty of
the same things as he's accusing the
prime minister of I just don't think
it's a very good way to conduct politics
you should focus on the issues and the
prime ministers demonstrated on this
subject in would he set out the other
week on cracking down on one aspect of
it which is on grooming gangs and he's
actually very tough on it and I think
that's how people will judge him you
talk a bit about the tone in politics
and what MPS are subjected to and it
just make me think about the story about
Stella Christie the labor MP where she
completely incredibly was contacted by
Social Services after someone said that
her children should be taken away
because of her views on men what's your
reaction to that well I think it's
terrible I think look we all disagree
with each other I don't always agree
with Stella about some of the campaigns
she runs but I think the treatment that
she's had to put up with is terrible the
treatment that many colleagues on my
side of the house have to put up with is
terrible I think all MPS of all parties
have to put are putting up with the law
and they shouldn't have to people in
politics you know we should all be able
to disagree uh have robust disagreements
but it shouldn't descend into people's
um families being attacked or their
personal lives being attacked I don't
think that's the right way to conduct
politics do you think Social Services
have questions to answer
well I don't know the specifics of that
case but I don't think people who are
attacked because of the job they do
um should have their personal lives
damaged in that way so I think you know
whoever's been involved in this should
look at the facts of the case and I
think it's clearly appalling
connections uh fast approaching uh
Kirsten says you should be making gains
the conservatives should be putting on
seats uh Oliver Darwin said last week
that he expects you to lose a thousand
seats so what is going on there is a
truth somewhere in the middle well look
we're obviously fighting very hard for
every vote but I mean I think look if
you look at the independent commentators
the independent experts in this case all
the very respected ones they're they're
forecasting you know it's not our
forecast they're forecasting that they
think we we might lose a thousand seats
so I mean if people want to judge things
that's sort of what the independent
experts
campaigning for every vote are they
saying that because of how bad the
situation is for your party when you
last thought these uh seats in 2019 when
Theresa May as Kirsten says apologize a
few weeks later resigned and that was
the end of having that's the Baseline
and you're saying you're gonna go
backwards well well no we're not saying
that look we're not well you are saying
that aren't you we're not commentators
we're participants in this process you
know we're going out making our
arguments very strongly and we're going
out knocking on doors fighting for every
vote all I'm saying is if you want to
judge where expectations are if you look
at what the independent experts are
saying they're suggesting they think
we're going to lose a thousand seats um
because it's tough at the moment we
acknowledge there's as tough on people
you know there's a war going on in
Europe we're recovering from the
pandemic inflation is high that is
pushing people's finances under pressure
and so it's difficult at the moment
we've obviously got very clear plan and
one of our our clear range of the five
priorities the Prime Minister has set
out is to have inflation to grow the
economy and to cut debt I think if we
can deliver on that this year things
will look much more promising but you
know it is tough at the moment I think
it's very sensible to acknowledge that
but look independent experts have made
their full course I just want to pick up
on that because they're not saying that
that's definitely going to happen a
thousand seats it's just in the range of
possibilities right well that's their
forecast look it's not their forecasters
it could be as bad as they're suggesting
that that's what might happen look what
might happen not what will happen so I
think it is important to qualify that in
the end politicians are not just cherry
pick the worst case scenario no no I'm
just saying that seems to be where
they're sort of saying is a sort of
expectation politicians though I think
since we're not to get into the
forecasting game we're about trying to
persuade every single person listening
to this program that they should vote
conservative because conservative
councils as ever deliver better services
at lower cost than labor and legal
Democrat Council so that's why people
should vote for their conservative
Council candidates uh nurses go on
strike from 8pm we're going to be
speaking to Pat Cullen of the Royal
College of nurses uh shortly uh what's
your message to her well look of the
payoff that was offered to NHS staff
which we think was a fair and reasonable
payoff some of the largest unions in the
NHS their members have accepted that at
pay deal and obviously the health sector
is going to wait formally until Tuesday
when the NHS staff Council which brings
together all of those unions formally
reports back to him but he stands ready
to implement that offer subject to
hearing from them finally so clearly a
lot of members working in the a lot of
workers in the NHS have accepted that
fair and reasonable payoff though and
he'll have to decide after Tuesday's
meeting what the next steps are but look
I'd say to PATCO look she I think agreed
that it was a fair and reasonable payoff
for because she and her her executive
recommended it to their members their
members obviously haven't accepted it
and obviously if it's going to cause
disruption in the NHS so I would urge
them to to think again and to do what
the other trade unions in the health
services are done which is except what I
think is a fair and reasonable payoff
for reflecting the value that we do
place on hard-working NHS stuff you say
that they should accept it because
others have but the point is I guess the
nurses who work for the RCN or the
majority of them didn't think it was the
right payoffer and you know if you look
at and pay pay the nurses going back
over the last decade they have seen
really difficult pay decisions made all
the way back since 2010 the average pay
of NHS nurses falling in real terms by
eight percent by since 2010 and Analysis
from the London economics saying that
the nurse has paid a client at twice the
rate of private sector pay you can see
why they feel that they should be given
you know decent pay rise well they
should be given a decent pay rise and I
think that's what they were offered if
you look at last uh inflation if you
look at um last year actually when there
was a public sector pay freeze this
specifically was a pay rise for nurses
to reflect the value that the government
places on them and the pay deal that
they were offered would have given a a
band five nurse so that's an average
nurse over the two years of that pay
dealer I think something in the order of
a five thousand pound pay rise so the
government believes it was a fair and
reasonable pay rise some of the other
staff groups the GMB and Unison have
accepted the pay rise so look the
secretary say well listen to what the
NHS staff Council says on Tuesday but he
stands ready I know to implement the pay
deal that was offered if if that's what
the NHS stealth Council report back on
Tuesday unlike other strikes um
originally there were no exemptions for
emergency care so things like cancer
treatment a e maternity they have now
after some hospitals like Great Ormond
Street and raise the alarm if you like
said that in some local areas they will
provide cover I our lives at risk over
the next couple of days well I think the
thing that's very difficult here is that
because they haven't agreed any national
exemptions it makes it very difficult
for those individual trusts and the
individual trust managers to put in
place arrangements to deal with those
areas like a e like cancer treatment so
what does that mean are you worried
about lines it clearly does put patients
at risk which is why we urge the the
unions not to go ahead and do the strike
um clearly if if
NHS staff are not working I mean all of
those trusts are going to work really
hard to put in place contingency
Arrangements at local level they'll all
be working with NHS staff to look at the
contingency arrangements and doing their
best but clearly there will be an impact
if nurses don't come to work
give us an update on restaurants as well
if you may
although I I think it's very damaging
that the rail unions are calling strikes
specifically targeting
um the Eurovision song contest I've I've
met with the head of Ukrainian Railways
the Ukrainian Railways have been
specifically targeted by Vladimir Putin
real because they're being killed in
their hundreds and I would have thought
frankly rail workers would have wanted
to stand in solidarity with them rather
than targeting Eurovision song contest
which if you remember it's not our song
contest we're hosting it but we're
hosting it for Ukraine and I think
cynically targeting events the
hard-working working men and women
across the country are spending their
money on to try and attend and targeting
those I think is very cynical there's
been a few do you take a bit of
responsibility for this as well right
because you know in Rishi cnx says that
he is the great deal maker that's how
he's trying to
portray himself as prime minister these
strikes have been going on for
absolutely months now and look if you
kind of zoom out we have a government
that is effectively the relationship
between the government and the people
who keep this country running has broken
down so the people who you know care for
our sick and Hospital the people who
teach our children the people who drive
the trains do you not take some
responsibility for that as well well
look when I got this job I thought it
was good to reset the relationship I met
all the Trade union leaders what hasn't
really worked well I remember you saying
to us and you know it has because if you
look at a lot of the workers in the rail
industry so rmt workers who work for
Network rails so that thousands of
workers who work on the infrastructure
actually they've had a fair and
reasonable payoff for rmt put it to
their members and the members
overwhelmingly accepted it 90 turnout 76
in favor What's Happening Here is that
the rmt executive isn't putting the
third payoff that they've had from the
train operating companies they're
refusing to put it to their members now
my view is if they put it to their
members if you look at what they did on
the network rail pay deal I think their
members would accept it so my call to
the union executive this is not aimed at
the hard-working men and women who work
on the railway their Executives should
put what is a fair and reasonable
payoffer it's very similar to the
network put it to their members let them
decide and not Target the Eurovision
Song Contest in the FA Cup Final hitting
hard-working men and women up and down
the country in this no long running just
be I'm talking about the rail Railways
I'm talking about the schools and
talking about the hospitals is there
something that you think in retrospect
the government should have done
differently well I think the
government's having to deal with two
very difficult things here about what
you have to do with what should you have
done differently like looking back and
being honest what should the government
have done differently well I think if
you look at the fact that take the NHS
which you were talking about if you take
the fact that actually the biggest trade
unions and their members have accepted
that they haven't done anything wrong I
don't know I'm the last no I'm not
saying that I'm saying anything wrong if
you look at the overall look we can all
go back and look at individual things
but if you look at the over oh no that's
what I'm asking you if you look at the
overall position we've made fair and
reasonable payoffers they've been
accepted Now by some of the biggest NHS
unions and network rail staff have
settled so you can't name a single thing
the government's done wrong I don't
think that's part of the problem no but
I don't I don't it's not very humble is
it when you're like these these are
people who like on on low-paid jobs many
of them working really hard and and you
can't say a single thing the
government's done wrong well I don't
think it's very I don't think it's very
helpful to just go back over the history
and think what could we have done
differently I'm focused just on what
we're doing going forward I think and by
the way on train drivers they're
actually pretty well paid actually the
average salary of a train driver is 60
000 pounds I've said many of the people
who are going on I'm talking about
nurses I'm talking about ambulance but
of the ones I'm about but the ones I'm
responsible for train drivers get 60 000
pounds a year the pay deals very easy to
pick like the one the one people the
whole group the pay deal they've been
offered would take their average salary
to nearly 65 000 pounds and they won't
even put that payoff to their members
and so my my argument
about 60 000 years no it no it isn't and
I wasn't pretending it was but that
we've made a fair and reasonable
payoffer to NHS staff which has been
accepted by the largest Health unions
the members of the largest Health unions
and as I said the secretary of state
will get their formal feedback on
Tuesday okay
um
we had the last flight out of Sudan the
ceasefire was coming to an end
what will happen to British Nationals
national team may still be in the
country
the the well the evacuation that we've
conducted is the longest and largest
evacuation of any Western Nation we've
taken out the
1888 British Nationals which I think is
a testimony to the hard work of both
those on the ground who've put
themselves at risk and also those
working
um uh HQ to get that evacuation in place
we've now got some staff based at Port
Sudan which is where we're going to
continue providing Consular support for
British Nationals that have chosen to
remain in the country but we we were
very clear with our messaging about the
need to get people out well the
ceasefire was in place you'll have seen
there was an attack on a Turkish
aircraft a couple of days ago
demonstrating that that evacuation was
not without risk and we therefore can't
stay there indefinitely but we were
clear with British citizens about the
need to get to the Airfield to evacuate
and I say we've taken out 1 888 British
Nationals and their dependents which I
think is a testimony to a very
successful evacuation effort and we will
continue providing Consular support from
Port Sudan there's a couple of other
things I was just Keen to get your
Reflections on um of course there's been
a lot of scrutiny about the BBC chairman
who stood down this week and resigned
should that appointment now be taken out
of government hands
the BBC of course is a a publicly
accountable institution funded by
through the license fee effectively by
taxpayers and that's why there's been a
long-standing Arrangement you know for
the BBC chair to be appointed by the
government that's been true under
parties of of governments of both
political parties that's a long-standing
Arrangement and we don't have any plans
to change it I guess
it's that something that this whole
Scandal came about because the
government under Boris Johnson was
trying to get their allies into this job
right so wouldn't the best thing to do
just to take all government
involvement out of the process going
forward well the BBC is funded
effectively by taxpayers not through
taxes but through the license fees so I
think it's important that the government
is involved in uh in making the
appointment and Michelle clearly
continue to implement the rules that are
long-standing so we've got no plans to
change them and I said those are the
rules that have been implemented by
governments of both parties and I think
they've worked well over over time and
you've got an announcement on uh scams
today just tell us what the idea is yes
areas of crime fraud is one of the big
areas that targets people so what we're
doing is cracking down and banning cold
calling of people trying to Market
Financial products
um so that we can then be clear with
people that you know if you receive a
cold call trying to Market these things
uh it'll be from somebody who shouldn't
be doing it to try and give people that
confidence it's one of the areas that
where crime is grown we're seeing crime
falling violent crimes falling
neighborhood crime is falling fraud is
one of the areas people are targeting
and the government's being tough and
cracking down on it hence the
announcement today and just finally um
there's lots in the papers about the
coronation uh next weekend people
watching on TV are going to be asked to
pledge allegiance to King Charles as
well I don't know where you're going to
be on the coronation are you going to be
pledging Allegiance yes well of course
members of parliament pledge allegiance
to his majesty uh as part of swearing
and vote for office so I've already
pledged allegiance to the king very
happy to do so again and I hope people
do I think look coronation is going to
be a fantastic opportunity not just to
focus on our history and our
constitutional matters but also it's
it's a great showcase for Britain around
the world we're going to have hundreds
of foreign dignitaries coming here and
it's a great opportunity I think for
Britain to demonstrate all about our
country that's great our fantastic
values and we can all get behind and
support
um his majesty the king okay thank you
very much thank you